(upbeat music)
- I think it's going to
be even more important
to have the widest range of
skillsets that you could have,
so less specialization,
more a jack-of-all-trades,
including design, design
thinking, design work,
together with that programming experience,
so that you can jump into the
new technological advances
that are being made every day.
We're gonna be so much
more in virtual reality,
can you not just use it,
but can you program it?
- I think the most important
ones will be curiosity
and keen-eyed observational skills.
See, curiosity fuels the question why,
which is an essential
part of every innovation,
and keen observational skills allow us
not to waste our effort
reinventing the wheel.
Life has already solved so
many of the toughest problems
that the world can possibly throw in it,
so why not figure out how
biology has overcome an obstacle
and adapt or improve on that?
(upbeat music)